no basketball game exist in a vacuum  it was come before what will follow  I need sport this boy is everything it's  what makes this chair and booth before  the game is even starting SEMA starts  what turns doesn't let vans and hate  haters it gives us on the doll upset  sinus buzzer-beaters classic rivalry at  its best the story could turn a jump  shot into the shower it's the story  got it swearing with dicks the oversized  jurors jumping on bad way of his name's  into our faith and this is story that  brings all together understand it's not  just a court  it's an epicenter for plotting fold and  the drama writes itself so  what will your story be NBA 2k16  starring spike Lee joint